so recently I was trying to decide
whether or not I should buy a wide-angle
lens for this camera and in order to
make that decision I employed the
timeless technique of the pros and cons
list in the process of making that list
I happen to discover that the pros cons
list technique something so simple than
it had to be used by a human since time
immemorial is actually a relatively
recent invention by none other than our
stupidly accomplished for father
Benjamin Frank in a somewhat hilarious
letter to Joseph Priestley in 1772
Franklin explains it thusly my way is to
divide half a sheet of paper by a line
into two columns writing over the one
pro and over the other con than during
three or four days consideration I put
down under different heads short hints
of the different motives that at
different times occur to me for or
against the measure when I have thus got
them all together in one view
accordingly now Franklin may merely have
been the first person to write this idea
down not the first to use it but it got
me thinking about concepts that appear
to me as timeless but which only seem so
because I'm trapped in this particular
place at this particular time for
example the number zero we use it every
day in conversation none not zip zilch
zero goose egg but as a concept zero
took many centuries to develop and a
number of our greatest minds to
comprehend fully the best mathematicians
of ancient Greece didn't even have a
name for zero it didn't like it does for
us serve as a placeholder for writing
big numbers it wasn't until 650 ad that
Indian mathematician Brahma Gupta
finally formalized how to reach 0
through addition and subtraction that
the concept took shape and it wasn't
fully understood for another thousand
years when Newton and Leibniz invented
calculus and what it actually means to
divide by zero from math totally normal
segue to sex though heterosexuality is
something we invoke to an almost
ridiculous degree in contemporary
society the term actually dates to the
mid 19th century and a letter written by
austro-hungarian journalist Carl Carrick
in the letter Kurt Benny coins the terms
for hetero and homosexuality as a way to
suggest that there's no hierarchy
between the two ways of life that
they're just different inborn
expressions of sexuality it wasn't until
later in the 19th century that
psychiatrists and psychoanalysts
established heterosexuality as a synonym
for normal and homosexuality is somehow
deviant before that people were
persecuted for a certain sexual acts
like sodomy or pedophilia the creation
and co-opting of these terms enabled the
persecution of orientation okay what
about the idea of ambition surely a
timeless concept for admirable striving
up the social ladder actually ambition
is only as old as the social ladder is
it wasn't until the Middle Ages that
social mobility became a viable option
for members of society before the 16th
century social position was ordained by
God and classes were hermetically sealed
part nobody not born there could get in
or even entertain the idea of doing so
ambition comes from the Latin and beer
which means to go around specifically to
go around canvassing for votes as in the
old Roman system in ancient times it was
always used as a negative term grouped
together with pride and vainglory
but when the Middle Ages ended and
modernity dawned the English word
ambition enters common usage as
something positive to legitimize and
reinforce the social-climbing of the new
world fast forward to today and it's
impossible to imagine office spaces
without posters like this
finally childhood a timeless archetype
of purity and innocence known in the
late 19th and 20th century children were
employed as labourers and their work was
seen as crucial to contributing to the
family income it was only after the
passing of a number of child labor laws
that prohibited them from work that
society began treating children in the
way that we think of now as explicitly
non-commercial as sacred imbued with an
almost religious purity instead of being
individuals meant to secure the future
for their parents the roles were
reversed and parents were obliged to
protect children from the harsh
realities of adult life and his children
cease to be productive economic forces
they re-emerged
the economy as consumers and the
sentimental space they occupy was
aggressively commercialized before the
shift in the culture the concept of
childhood was much less hallo to the
point that even the death of a child was
received with a certain amount of
aloofness and detachment Zelizer quotes
a contemporary man on the subject to
lose a child when first brought into
life is very hard but it is a tax we
must pay it's an attitude that's hard to
imagine in a time like ours when the
most horrific and emotionally painful
event of recent memory was the death of
twenty young children in Newtown
Connecticut in 2012 the majority of
those who died today were children
beautiful little kids between the ages
of five and ten years old I'm not making
a value judgment on any of these shifts
in our culture for me it's extremely
humbling to know that my conception of
human nature is merely a reflection of a
moment in history many if not all of
these things are historical accidents
not some great fulfillment of the way
humanity was always going to advance
they expressed the wills of individuals
enmeshed in moralities as blind to the
past as we are the more we understand
that fact the more benevolent our own
blind push forward will be thank you all
for watching this is my friend Maya
she's here to tell you that if you were
interested in this topic there's a
couple of other videos I did in which I
explore these topics one on concept of
love and one on the concept of logic and
I'll put the links here that you can
click on Maya really wants to tell you
to subscribe to this channel follow me
on tumblr and twitter and make sure that
you stick around for the next one sorry
I've been absent for the last couple
weeks but listen there's important
things going on
he's back I'm back see you next time